et on commence avec le film présenté à
deauville mais aussi dans les salles de
cinéma c'est sur la route de madison le
nouveau film de clint eastwood avec
clint eastwood mais également meryl
streep à nicolet victor us les hacker
jim eni d'après le best-seller
sentimentale 11 millions de lecteurs aux
états unis de roberts james oler qui
aurait dit et je le précise chez albin
michel histoire les très simple c'est
celle de francesca johnson qui est marié
infirmier qui a deux enfants
lui c'est robert king s'est dit les
photographes il fait un reportage sur
les ponts couverts de madison county
ayant perdu son chemin il s'arrête dans
la ferme ou francesca et pour une fois
tout à fait seul et pendant quatre jours
de l'été 1965 la jolie fermière et le
beau reporters vont vivre une aventure
passionnel c'est du grand mélo
d'ailleurs ça dure deux heures quinze ou
serge toubiana dans les cahiers du
cinéma a vu un film politique et morale
lancée contre l'idéologie du
politiquement correct
là où beaucoup de simples spectateurs
comme nous ne verront qu'un mail euros
et qu'un film d'ailleurs fort bien joué
et réalisé mais c'est un film politique
à ce point thierry c'est un des aspects
du film c'est pas le seul effectivement
bon policier pas mal ou non ça n'est pas
du tout un film démonstrative ne lasse
non c'est un film sur qui parle quand
même d'une chose qui effectivement est
très importante aux états unis
visiblement est particulièrement
aujourd'hui c'est un film qui parle de
la famille et de l'amour bon c'est ça
paraît un peu cucul quand on ne s'est
pas aux états unis cela dit non mais non
mais c'est vrai qu'on sait que la
majorité morale aux états unis a pris
une importance de plus en plus grand de
ces dernières années enfin repris une
importance de plus en plus grand de ces
dernières années et c'est vrai qu'il ya
une idéologie un peuple qui commence à
peser de plus en plus force est à la
fois sur le cinéma et d'ailleurs
et sur la société de façon générale bon
je vais pas m'étendre là dessus parce
que c'est pas forcément pour moi
l'aspect le plus le plus direct le plus
directement fort du film même si je
pense qu'il se tournait plutôt qui a été
longtemps considéré comme un cinéaste de
droite est plutôt quelqu'un qui a une
sensibilité anarchiste
cette part film trotsky n'a pas tapé
thompson non mais c'est un peu comme
john ford c'est à dire que c'est un
cinéaste au dot on sait qu'il a été
plutôt d'opinion républicaine pendant
longtemps est en fait pour moi c'est
quelqu'un qui a une sensibilité plutôt
anarchiste sans en faire c'est pas
ravachol mais c'est bon cela dit moi je
trouve c'est surtout un film absolument
passionnant
sur la mise en scène est sûre finalement
un film c'est un film qui ne fonctionne
pas de parent pratiquement pas sur le
scénario
ce qui est quand même très étonnant là
aussi donc on dit que les très bons dit
que les américains sont les grands
spécialistes du scénario qui savent
mieux écrire des histoires que nous et
au fond il tout prouve que la force du
cinéma américain en tout cas sa force à
lui comme cinéaste
d'ailleurs moi je trouve je considère
que c'est le plus grand cinéaste
américain actuel c'est pas forcément son
plus grand fils mais moi je crois que
c'est son plus grand enfin que c'est le
plus grand cinéaste américain actuel
c'est un film qui repose entièrement sur
la mise en scène et sur la direction
d'acteurs est d'une certaine manière sur
le dialogue et là-dessus bon il ya des
choses moi j'avais très peur quand je
suis allé voir le film parce qu'on avait
dit le best seller c'est un film
sentimental
bon c'est un fils livre est assez
accablant tout à coup je n'ai pas lu
mais j'imagine mais je trouve que
eastwood en a fait un film très
personnel
il a réussi à rendre meryl streep une
actrice quasiment fascinante ce qui est
vraiment super directrice comme moi
j'aime beaucoup que je trouve qu'elle a
beaucoup de tic en général là je trouve
qu'elle est extrêmement attachante non
je ne suis pas du tout fan de meryl
streep supérieur et je la tragi ce que
ce duo
ce duo il se trouvera ce deal with ce
duo eastwood mais de la même manière
qu'il avait rendu kevin cosner rien dans
le précédent film ce qui était aussi
d'une certaine manière un exploit à mon
sens et mais ça c'est personnel
non cela dit je dois pas faire toutes
les missions non plus non non je trouve
que ce duo entre eastwood et meryl
streep fonctionne admirablement bien
c'est un film extrêmement émouvant et
est en plus très personnelle parce qu'il
soude reprendre des manières le
personnage qui jouait dans ce western
c'est à dire une sorte de fantôme qui
finalement apparaît à cette femme et qui
lui offre un moment comme ça de grâce
suspendu et surtout c'est un très beau
fils et câbles et hervé à la sat ou l'a
pas vu longtemps les choses pareilles
sans pouvoir riposter mais ça tu n'as
pas vu non je n'ai pas vu parce qu'il
n'était pas encore sorti à l'époque
philippe collin oui moi je suis beaucoup
moins emballé parce que je trouve très
sûrement pour moi un des plus mauvais de
eastwood que je trouve d'une lourdeur et
d'une pesanteur absolument un câble en
moi ce film si vous voulez me semble
mais je ne réagissais pas trop vite et
c'est moi m'expliquer geanah presse je
ne fais pas de différence fondamentale
entre ce film et et die hard 3 une
journée en enfer je veux dire par là que
le scénario est évidemment complètement
l' inverse puisque c'est un scénario
sentimentale très peu de personnages non
compléter ou plus fier c'est que les
sondés en aura tout le contraire dans
cette volonté de d'efficacité à tout
prix enfin qui est absolument
fantastique fantastiquement besoins et
les plaisanciers dire que tout est fait
qu'est ce que c'est qu'est ce que c'est
l'histoire n'est fait il n'y a pas de
scénario c'est de savoir que ces deux
personnes sont faites pour aller au lit
alors en 48 heures chrono en 36 heures
chrono ils ont quatre juste un grand
angle est ce vraiment si c'est en effet
aussi à suspense en effet comme un autre
mais cela dit c'est qui c'est que tout
tout est mis en place avec une énergie
mots-clés américain actuel pour que tout
soit le plus le plus efficace possible
c'est à dire que la musique par exemple
on nous déverse absolument dans le col
de la chemise comme cette espèce de
sirop d'orgeat tienne qui cote
enfin moi j'ai le 10 comme envoyer aussi
les écouter cette musique cette musique
à part ça est-ce que n'ose pas mettre je
veux dire un cadre en goguette pour
essayer nous lie est le fait c'est quand
même un peu barré week-end à deauville
mais l'aspect guévariste du film dérobé
ce match toujours que meryl streep et un
accent alors elle a un petit peu cet
accent italien
mais surtout pour bien montrer que comme
on vient d'italie c'est que la passion
bout toujours depuis depuis que le puits
canna magnani est allé manger c'est
juste dans un film de gore yann et leur
l'italienne elle est prête à y aller dès
que le mari de poncifs cette nostalgie
de l'amérique refonte des années 60
alors comme si tout à coup non plus ils
nous lâchent un peu sur les années
trente ans maintenant c'est des années
oui c'était juste 64 c'est juste après
la mort de kennedy mais à mon avis ils
sont un peu loin ils ne savent pas
encore là le paysage est absolument s'y
perd alors toute la tête politique
philippe pas du tout c'est une affaire
politique absolument cesser mener si
vous dire que ce soit des explosions des
attentats c'est une scène d'amour la
petite dispute la petite danse dans la
cuisine d'un typhon gipa non ce soir
même plus tôt demain matin etc
enfin c'est bien filmé alors attendons
nous parce que moi j'aime beaucoup c'est
un jour en enfer raisons n'ont jamais
appelé j'en ai séjourné avec une journée
en journée on en fait mais je trouve
très exceptionnellement là parce que moi
je les aime beaucoup les films de clint
eastwood tomber ou du moins sacrifiés
volontairement non je ne sais pas
pourquoi à cette espèce de cinéma qui
est fait comme la guerre enfin c'est à
dire c'est vraiment faire foncer faire
table rase de toutes les bêtises de
toutes les ambiguïtés pour aller et et
servir servir bien fait parfaitement
fait un spectacle de deux soupes
sentimentale qui n'a pas énormément
d'intérêt métier d'une évidemment
photographiquement d'une qualité se
tient le coup thierry et moi je il
faudra répondre à ces à cette vision du
film par philippe collin parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'on n'a vraiment pas vu
le même fille parce que quand il parle
d'efficacité des grilles ma fille ou les
plans dieu extrêmement longtemps c'est
un film qui n'est jamais fait sur le
montage ou sur les choses sur les effets
justement quels sont ceux résidant dans
les films d'action donc c'est quand même
à des cinéastes qui fume le plus
en plan séquence
je veux dire c'est quand même ça n'a
rien à voir à mon avis avec l'efficacité
américaine donc on voit dans les films d
pensif jade titilleur en plans séquences
audio de la parole presse un poncif de
montrer justement joignable d'accord
d'accord à part ça si la miss tout mais
ça non mais moi je trouve c'est pas des
poncifs de montrer une histoire 5 entre
un monsieur est à moi je trouve que la
mise en scène est très belle et ce qui
se passe justement ce qu'il arrive à
faire de cette histoire qui n'en est pas
une
en fait qu'elle n'ait pas n'y a pas
d'histoire est justement de nommer de
fer avec justement sa mise en scène qui
joue toujours sur le temps parce que le
la marque 10 tout c'est quand même de
faire des plans très long et d'essayer
que dans ses plans il se passe quelque
chose et ça je trouve ça assez bien et
tout alors sur l'amérique oui parce
qu'il dit quand même ce qu'il pense de
l'amérique ce qu'il pense de la famille
américaine je sais quand même pas
possible qu'il ait pris ce fils est
cette fille qui découvre le passé de
leur mère les choses et des choses aussi
claude girard ans tout ce que j'y
raconte critiquer ce que j'ai raconté
cette un flashback les enfants on
retrouve entre autres histoires à des
enfants sont tellement bêtes tellement
stupide et tellement idiot que c'est pas
possible que ce soit un volontaire de la
part disent tout c'est à dire qu'ils
lançaient pas fomenté ces violences les
lance du plénum de l'esprit non parce
que parce qu'en effet la morale disent
toutes ces il aurait dû peut-être vivre
ensemble donc c'est un espèce de
romanesque pour le grand problème pour
moi c'est qu'autant je trouve qui soude
est très très bien autant je trouve
meryl streep que j'aimais bien il ya
quelques années comme toi eastwood tu
vois c'est à dire au mans de voyage aux
couleurs des aveux oui mais voyage au
bout de l'enfer était super bon et voilà
maintenant elle est insoutenable dire
que l or est insoutenable insoutenable
quel iphone vantant la trouvez
maintenant et maintenant elle trouve des
d'éthique sterckeman ans elle a trouvé
pour ces personnes la préfère à devant
ballet qu'il fallait mettre les mains
comme ça sur ces jours pour être agréé
l'émotion ça devient plus de talent
attends attends mais elle a le droit
nous mais elle a le droit de faire ça
pour devenir un personnage seulement
elle ne fait pas que ça c'est un
festival de deux doigts sur deux doigts
sur va rétrocéder le monde
le truc c'est de la patate adoré le film
pierre j'aime bien la mise en scène dix
tours et j'aime bien eastwood qui en
fait le moins possible et face à lui il
est espèce de bonne femme qui dès qu'il
fait rien on fait le plus possible on
dirait une espèce de dessin animé on est
en action comme ça le fait ça l'fait s'y
est fait ça dans toutes les chaînes à la
radio on va pas tes rêves un oui marc
face et on peut peut-être se deviner
c'est qu'elle passe la main sous le nez
souvent en ton sur les cheveux etc
c'est un festival de cabotinage qui à
peu près digne de dustin hoffman dans
rain man quoi eh bien c'était sur la
route de radisson les films de clint
eastwood réfugiés à deauville le film
est même très bien
[Musique]